foreign
[Music]
thing we've all learned is that there is
nothing worse than a national dialogue
very often after a tragedy or Scandal of
some kind we're told by the media that
it's time for a national dialogue
sometimes the dialogue is about gun
violence or hate or homophobia or sexism
or mental health and it's always the
media that announces this dialogue and
the media that proceeds to have the
dialogue a dialogue that always turns
out to be more of a monologue the media
talks about the subject that we're all
supposed to listen that's how the
dialogues are always meant to go so this
week we and and by we I mean they the
media have been having another dialogue
and this one is about violence in
football in light of the Demar Hanlon
incident yesterday reporters even tried
to get the president of the United
States to chime in on this subject of
violence in football but they were
rebuffed due to the fact that the
president of the United States is well a
vegetable listen
I think NFL is getting too dangerous no
look
the idea that you're gonna have
you got
guys that are
six eight
340 pounds
running uh four eight forty
I mean you know
it hits somebody with that kind of
forward now that's not what happened
here
but I just think it's a
I don't know how you avoid it
ah well he has a point it's impossible
to say what his point is but I'm sure he
has one over on The View uh the football
experts sitting around the table had a
slightly only slightly more coherent
conversation about the topic but still
very stupid
there's
right I mean my kid played football he
was recruited for college and he got a
terrible hamstring injury getting hit
and I saw him collapse into the ground
thank you and um he went through
physical therapy for six months and he
realized at that point uh-oh I could
that could happen to my brain yeah and
so he quit and it was he did he quit and
it was a very hard thing for him because
he loved doing it
um and I but I don't think it's going to
turn people away from the sport because
I mean I went to Notre Dame it's like
Faith Family football it's a big deal
and it's 105 billion dollar industry so
45 of Americans think that tackle
football is appropriate
heterosexual men voted the most support
for kids uh doing football and
conservatives were more likely to
support youth tackle football just
saying just saying heterosexual men
enjoy football so it must be bad
with a take like that Joe Behar Joy
Behar May uh may have just earned
herself a show on ESPN actually
meanwhile the news media has contributed
to the National dialogue with headlines
like these
fans grapple with football's violent
pull after Hamlin collapse and we're all
complicit in the NFL's violent spectacle
and then the terrifying collapse of
Demar Hamlin and the everyday violence
of football but the first place prize
for insufferability has to go to the
Washington Post article which is titled
after the hoopla all that's left is the
NFL's violence this is written by a
woman named Robin givan who has likely
never actually seen a football game and
couldn't discern a first down from a
field goal but the piece begins with
this paragraph
from a distance from outside the circle
of fans and aficionados professional
football is both confounding and
enraging it's America's most popular
sport and is also deliberately
unspeakably violent it's a particular
kind of violence that's less about
accidental collisions adrenaline fueled
fist fights or even a singular
articulated blow football violence is
wrapped up in machismo militarism
Swagger and patriotism it isn't a sport
that thrives despite the violence
but because of it
now she's exactly right about the last
couple of sentences there and that's
precisely what makes football so great
she goes on for many other uh paragraphs
continuing to criticize football in
terms that just make it sound all the
more appealing to many of us especially
many of us men she says football is a
particularly American sport although it
certainly has fans in other countries
notably in Germany Britain and Canada
but the NFL doesn't have the sort of
international rosters that one finds
among nades the Nations baseball and
basketball teams there is no American
football World Cup football is America's
violence
in football the player wears the where
players wear their helmets and pads to
provide them some protection but all
that gear is also a recognition that the
game is in fact predicated on men
injuring other men they give each other
a bruising they put a hurt on each other
they go to war Americans love their
football they're loyal to their favorite
teams fans admire football players
athleticism their impressively complex
tactics and the competitive Spirit of a
Super Bowl but in the last decade much
of the Romanticism that once surrounded
football has disintegrated to more
clearly reveal the racism and the
corporate offices the sexism with any
culture and the enduring physical pain
of the game all that's left is the
violence and Americans settle into their
seats for that they tailgate in
anticipation of their volatile pastime
this orchestrated pummeling of another
team the walloping of another person
the Winner's Victory is a violent one
so to review
um football is violent Macho Matilda
militaristic brutal patriotic and
uniquely American
this is supposed to be an argument
against football but it ends up being a
better advertisement for football than
anything the NFL would come up with
these days hey that is a better NFL
advertisement than any NFL advertisement
I have seen in 10 years
and that's the funny thing here is that
the media is discovering football's
violence at precisely the moment that
the NFL is doing everything it can to
neuter and feminize the sport and make
it less violent professional football in
fact has never been less violent than it
is right now
and yet now is the time when reporters
are asking the president whether
football is becoming too dangerous
now whatever else you might say about
the sport there is no doubt that is
actually becoming every year
significantly less dangerous for better
or worse
but even with all the additional focus
on safety
and the new rules introduced every year
to make the sport less physical and less
brutal
um still it remains a sport a contact
sport
and so injuries are possible
serious injuries are also possible fatal
injuries are extremely unlikely and
incredibly rare but still possible
anybody with a brain knew this already
every player knows this we have all
always been aware of the possibility
which is why it doesn't make sense to
engage in some sort of fundamental
reassessment of the sport when the
possible thing which we all knew was
possible happens to Mar Hamlin is a
tragic occurrence it's not new
information though
it's the sort of thing that everyone
knows can happen
and so when it does happen it just
doesn't make any sense to say well we
got to reassess all of this it's like if
there's if there's a terrible car
accident and somebody dies in The Cars
Demar Hamlin thank God is has is didn't
die in this is has survived so far but
if there's a terrible car accident
and you're sad about the car accident it
doesn't make any sense to say well now
we have to reassess and and rethink of
everything about the highway system I
was like we always knew why would this
you always knew that there were
accidents
so why is this causing you to think
differently about it
but putting that aside for a moment
and even putting the NFL aside let's
consider football itself as a sport
despite any rule changes or updates to
the equipment it is still a
fundamentally violent sport that's true
and and and that's what it always will
be
is that a bad thing no it's not
in fact it is a good and healthy thing
it is good that football is violent it
should stay violent it is good to have
violent Sports
okay we should have violent Sports if
anything we should have more of them
because a violent sport like football is
among other things
a relatively safe relatively safe and
relatively productive outlets for male
energy and aggression
okay there's a reason why many of the
media articles being written and
freaking out about football are being
written by women
because football is not no matter what
the NFL is trying to do football is not
for women there might be some women who
get into it but it's not really forward
it's not for you you don't understand it
you're not meant to understand it this
is actually a man's thing
this is why violent games have existed
in every society going back to primitive
times they are a means of channeling and
harnessing male aggression
part of the reason any boy or young man
starts playing football is that he
enjoys the contact the violence the
opportunity to hit someone yes that is
one of the things that is going to drive
a boy to play football again is that he
wants to hit someone
boys enjoy violence they do that might
make your tummy hurt to think about you
might put your uh hand on your forehead
and faint over the thought that boys
enjoy violence it doesn't change the
fact that they do boys naturally enjoy
violence my sons are constantly
wrestling and beating the hell out of
each other for fun my daughters never do
that with each other my boys do it all
the time
they love when I join in and wrestle
with them as well which I often do it's
what guys do it's how we're wired in
football or in any number of similar
Sports a boy learns to channel that
energy according to the rules and the
Playbook and in service to a greater
good which is the team now they're not
out fighting for their country they
aren't actually warriors on a
battlefield there isn't much really at
stake it's just a game sure but the
focus on the team working towards a
common goal utilizing that violent
energy in a disciplined and targeted way
between the whistles between the
sidelines this is all very good we need
to have Outlets like this we need to
have ways for young men to harness and
use that brutal masculine violent energy
that scares Washington Post columnist
and Joy Behar
the problem though is that we are
steadily removing all such Outlets from
society we're giving boys fewer and
fewer opportunities to be rambunctious
and violent in controlled and productive
environments
instead we attempt to suppress those
Tendencies entirely and feminize them
but it doesn't work it never will
and we again and again react with horror
when the male aggression we've been
trying to suppress and which has which
has few healthy outlets for expression
anymore spills out in far more dangerous
and destructive and chaotic ways on
street corners in classrooms Etc
here's the fact of the matter
you will never have a society without
Violent Men it cannot exist it never
will
the only question is whether men will be
given constructive avenues for
channeling and using that aggression or
not
if you choose not
there will be a price to pay
we are already paying it
and that is why the people trying to
cancel football
are instead themselves today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block and you can become a member and
use code walls to check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you over there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]